this is what it's come to
the once revered New York Times the
paper of record has now become the paper
of rumor as part of its unrelenting
vendetta against President Trump The
Times today published a column by
someone whom they do not identify the
senior Trump staffer under the cloak of
anonymity spins a wildly unflattering
tale of a president supposedly unhinged
from reality making impulsive decisions
that supposedly blindside and frustrate
top officials horan perpetual damage
control of course almost on cue the
press went wild in a stunning new op-ed
in The New York Times that unnamed tops
park administration official excoriates
the president and reveals a resistance
bloc within the Trump team trying to
protect the country from the commander
in chief it is an extraordinary piece in
the New York Times that really backs up
Bob Woodward's book the column in The
New York Times is extraordinary I've
never seen anything like this in modern
president his presidential history this
is incredibly unusual almost
unprecedented okay I'm sorry
I just watch them and I howl it's like
the roadrunner and the coyote all over
again
all right the gist of the piece by the
way is that you the people are lucky
that Trump is checked by a noble band of
staffers the writer included of course
they refer themselves to themselves as
part of the resistance
well the column further alleges that the
root of the problem is the president's
immorality he is not more to any
discernible first principles well
America first is either too difficult a
concept for the calmness to understand
or he just disagrees with it altogether
the president's agenda was clearly laid
out in the campaign and pursued
aggressively in his first 20 months in
office lower taxes less regulation
stronger border enforcement less
military intervention ISM and fairer
trade deals oh and let's not forget
pledged to appoint judges who are
faithful to their article 3 duties under
the Constitution Brett Kavanaugh comes
to mind if mr. or miss anonymous loathes
the Trump agenda so much well he or she
has no business being in the White House
this is not a loyal public servant this
is a disgruntled employee part of the
failed GOP establishment that lost power
and now want it back by any means
necessary Anonymous is a mole and a
fraud you know this has the feel of the
flim-flammery of the steel dossier
doesn't it constructed in advance by
Trump's vicious political opponents and
that's what the dossier the American
people have no way of judging the
veracity of its outlandish and
defamatory claims so we're supposed to
just take the word of trumps adversaries
no questions asked
how convenient the column is rife with
all these dramatic flourishes intended
to titillate and feed the media beasts
like this line the president continues
to act in a manner that is detrimental
to the health of our republic how about
his actions policies that have improved
the lives of millions of Americans
including African Americans Latino
Americans women small business owners
etc etc is all that detrimental the
Republic anonymous claims he wants the
president to be successful and does
admit some of these accomplishments but
he insists that these successes have
come despite not because of the
president's leadership style which is
impetuous adversarial petty and
ineffective
okay sure you know Trump can be
impatient and loses his cool you know
Inez can be frustrating struck
frustrated as all of us are with the
pace of Washington and of course also
with the media big whoop and if I had to
guess and I'm just guessing here I'd say
that somewhere along the line mr.
no-name probably had his widow
wings hurt by the president two words
man up if you think so highly of
yourself and really stand by your claims
step forward and identify yourself
the kicker in this piece is when
anonymous claims that the cabinet
officials so distraught by the president
even toyed with the idea of invoking the
25th amendment this blared across all of
cable news it lays out the path for
removal of the president in cases of
quote inability and that's a term that
has never been defined or tested the
idea that the 25th amendment would ever
be used is is really hard to contemplate
that we're at that point
why won't Paul Ryan Mitch McConnell
today convene a hearing on the 25th of
month I would haul up political
appointees from every agency and ask who
talked about invoking the 25th amendment
and what did you see thank you William O
Douglas well make no mistake this is
part of a persistent drumbeat it started
in the wake of the election the deep
state with its faceless nameless sources
launched their own internal campaign
against Trump
then the beat was taken up by everyone
from Michael Wolff to even the esteemed
Bob Woodward the president should be
judged by his policies and the results
that he delivers for the American people
not by the embittered tails of a
would-be whistleblower hiding behind the
skirts of the gray lady and that's the
angle